young men are leaning extremely
conservative nowadays oh yeah yeah three
days ago yeah and what that means for
for the future and stuff if you have
women that don't look to get married and
you don't have a Revival of of
um
a Revival of conservative values or or
you know Traditional Values among women
the same way that you do among young men
because if you look at that that graph
or whatever the the the they were they
had never been further apart men and
women their political leanings women are
voting women exclusively young unmarried
women are keeping the Democrat Party
alive every other it seems like every
other uh um group is is actually voting
for for or is at least not strongly
Democrat and it's at the end of the day
that if if men can't make families then
they make more no this this my
prediction here whatever that does
happen the Democrats done
the Democrats are done with this metric
showing that 12th grade boys are like
what is it like four to one conservative
and the women are like uh I think it's
three to one liberal those young women
will be conservative in five years I
don't think there's any conflict between
what you're saying what I'm saying
because you're saying the Democrats are
done probably because those women in
five years will be conservative I'm
saying that young men that don't get
that don't have the option of having not
starting families they won't end up with
families because if you look at the
numbers the numbers that that that the
guy that uh that this video presented
don't line up with that at all but well
they're gonna have families here's to
tell you why it's because men are object
oriented and women are subject oriented
and the young women who have strong
emotional desires for uh for socializing
men with men are going to start to be
pulled in the men's Direction not the
other way around is there a problem that
this I mean you're saying five years but
that's basically their senior year of
college and the the reason reason that
women are predominantly Democrat voters
is because they're also the predominant
College attendees and they're going to
be saddled with massive debt and unable
to live on their own so they're going to
have to appeal to the conservative uh
you know construction worker it's not
that they have to it's that women are
going to go out what what is what what
are the tropes and and the stereotypes
women uh uh talk about men men talk
about things
if that is only a tendency that women
are more interested in social
interactions between men and women and
men are interested in their goals or
whatever women will be seeking ways to
interact with men like
I don't see a there there's going to be
a scenario and we've we already see it
now in the data where you have young men
who are Democrats and it appears to be
because they're what biologists call and
again this is a legitimate literal term
sneaky this is the actual
biological term
uh biologists use the term sneaky
to describe a situation where you say
you have the the alpha male oh I've
heard about this yeah the sneaky
sneaks in the middle of the night bangs
the women to procreate so it's so you
have the the man who bangs on his chest
and Roar and lifts muscles and attracts
women and then you have the sneaky
who sneaks in and weasels his way
yes
that's the male thing right right but
with young men skewing more and more
conservative if women want to have these
social interactions with men they're
going to have to meet men where they're
going there's there's not enough women
that want to so okay no yeah I I don't
think you understand what they want the
fact that we can see social Contagion on
on Instagram young women developing
Tourette's it's not an issue of of women
coming together and having a women's
meeting and being like we're not going
to listen to these men it's that they're
going to be talking about the guys they
like and all the guys are going to be
conservative so something's going to
have to break where the women are
talking to each other and they're going
to be like but he's not woke there's no
other guy you you either you the all the
guys at school the athletes the
musicians the rock stars the writers
they're all skewing conservative any
woman who wants to date a guy is going
to be dating a guy who's moderate to
conservative and then they're gonna have
to start listening to these other women
who are going to be saying things like
Well you're dating this far right guy
and they'll be like who are you dating
nobody yeah not a single person I think
it's going to depend on if they want to
have families because I don't even I've
never really understood why you would
date a left-leaning man when it comes to
starting a family because so so rarely
are they actually on that path anyways
so I'm I'm I'm surprised this trend
hasn't already reverted where women as
they get into their late 20s early 30s
they start to pursue more conservative
Leading Men because they want to have
kids women become more conservative
after they get married and I think
culturally right now marriage is not a
priority for men or women I think that
there are a lot of women who should
prioritize but I think in both Spears
there are men who are like I'm
conservative but I'm gonna put off
getting married or whatever else it's
true in both spaces both men and women
should want marriage for it to become a
more noteworthy Trend I will say uh you
have to remember that after 2016 there
are all these uh feminist journalists
who came out saying I can remember one
article specifically being like I keep
sleeping with this Trump supporter and I
I can't stop like he's everything I hate
but I I really want to sleep with him so
like there is obviously something too
yeah yeah that happens to all the time
can't stop it anyways I can't stop
sleeping with Trump supporters male
Trump supporters I wish I could stop but
I can't no but it's interesting uh be
because I think there is there is desire
among women for traditionally male
afterwards in a way that's undeniable so
the majority of women in every age group
every generation right now identifies as
a feminist right it's something like
between 53 to 67 in every generation but
obviously that's not true for the number
of men who identifies a male feminist so
how do they partner up it either means
that they're in their feminist in name
only they're willing to give it up and
when they get married they again lots of
couples become more most women are if I
understand correctly most women are not
super committed to politics like they're
more interested in like their life I
think there's a huge Spectrum right and
you know I think women do talk about men
they also just generally are more
interested in social dynamics and that
is one of the benefits of having women
in society is they're going to tell you
who's fighting and all sorts of things I
mean Remember The Stereotype of the
powerful businessman whose wife then
throws a dinner party where he networks
with whoever right like there is a there
is a a positive symbiotic relationship
between men and women women in
traditionally gendered roles I think the
the trend of teenage boys becoming more
conservative will inspire some teenage
girls to be more openly conservative but
I think generally it's always on the
cusp anyway so there's population
collapse coming from multiple countries
it's happening in the west we've got
like what 1.2 or something like that
kids per couple per person there's a
population collapse coming there's a
significant uh portion of women that
don't ever want to get married the P the
people that but men too I mean I think
it's not but it's not it's not as it's
not as pronounced with men because men
don't like women look for like specific
things in guys guys look for women like
it's real different what women are
looking for in a man no incentive for
men to get married right now really like
you could partner up with girl you could
have her move in you could pay for her
like you guys could have one kid like
the for women they don't want to get
married because they think in some way
they'll be oppressed but actually there
are all sorts of Legal Financial reasons
reasons for women to want marriage so
it's complete brainwashing so unless men
are also loudly speaking about why
marriage is good we'll just continue
down this trend of girls being like ah I
don't think so except for this new
cultural element which is that men are
starting to be more openly conservative
at a younger age well this this is a bit
of a tangent but I think it's important
to to consider you know Japan and
there's other nations where you've seen
these kind of population uh implosions
China too to a certain extent
um and it it's quite evident that the
United States is on in that as well as
most of you know Western Europe and
things like that
um I'm not at all convinced that we
aren't going to just kind of spiral into
that like I know uh that was the point
that I was that I was trying to make in
the first place is like because of the
way that that the the population
or the marriage statistics and stuff are
and there the the number of young men
that are not getting married and that
aren't going to be if you have young men
that don't get into families they get
into fights they get into trouble they
and that means they get into to war and
that is something that has happened
throughout history and as as long as we
have young men that are not married and
can't meet women they have no reason to
settle down like what like you're saying
men don't have a reason to settle down
women give men the reason to chill out
because they want you know they want to
hang out with the girl they want to get
laid they want to hang out with their
wife whatever if they don't have that
reason they want to get out go out and
get buckwild
after thinking my point is that we are
seeing this data showing 12th grade boys
are skewing conservative and 12th grade
girls are skewing liberal and give that
a few years and the women are going to
drift towards the men not the other way
around it's possible Dave Smith has a
great bit which I will not do justice so
I will not even try uh but it was about
how his wife uh he she finds him in this
alley he's an alley cat and then she
just lays out milk and slowly lures them
into the house and I I feel like that's
the the problem is that when you have a
more uh you know leftist leaning woman
they're not going to put out that saucer
of milk because cause they're not
interested in attracting The Alley Cat
male so like when will that Trend change
where the women actually want to settle
down and I'm not sure that it will
happen
Society I think I think the issue is
this young men are object oriented
typically young women are subject
oriented typically that means if a guy
is a skateboarder he's going to find
himself hanging out with a bunch of
other guys skateboarding they are going
to be so his draw will be I want to go
skateboard with my friends
the young women their draw will be I
want to engage in socialization the men
are off skateboarding all with each
other sharing ideas making jokes being
offensive and being guys they're skewing
conservative they're listening to Jordan
Peterson they're listening to Andrew
Tate
one day at the park you've got a handful
of young guys skateboarding and a
handful of girls and those guys are like
hey these girls are pretty attractive
then the girls are going to reach some
kind of impasse with wow they like one
of those guys was playing an Andrew Tate
video we can't be associated with that
one of those women is going to be like I
kind of want to be hanging out with some
of these guys like I want to I want to I
like we are social creatures more so
than the men are that means that there's
going to be competition among the women
for in terms of socializing to
go to these guys this is why like you
mentioned women become more conservative
when they get married that same poll I
think is going to happen and it's going
to realign young women towards more
moderate conservative views from your
lips to God's ears man I don't know I
think when men and women interact
especially when they get married a lot
of stuff changes I mean studies bear out
that uh when couples get when couples
have kids they become more religious
they tend to attend churches more
regularly there are stuff that I think
when you are a single individual you
don't prioritize in your life because
you know you're you're not as important
right your goals are just different but
as soon as you start having this intense
bond to someone else through marriage
and having children with them everything
shifts and so it's just interesting that
it's it's reaching teenage boys and the
decisions that they make like you're
saying by the time they're senior in
college will be very different than the
two generations before them yeah well
and I and I think my hope is that there
there's it's quite evident to me that
there's a lot of sadness and loneliness
and
purposelessness and rudderlessness I'm
gonna stop saying this is this is too
hard
um amongst young people in this country
and like so much of our I mean just
empirically speaking there's so much of
what humans uh passion and purpose is on
existing is to be a parent to be a
father a mother
um and I just pray that like even though
I'm not religious I still I pray that
people will find that pathway to purpose
once again because it's it's quite clear
to me that there's a lot of people that
are are desperate yeah and I think the
purpose of speeds are uh our culture
self-obsession right this if you have
nothing to do or work on you tend to
just be completely obsessed with
whatever's happening inside your own
head yes which narcissistic egotistical
and and also psychotic I mean you know
you basically go crazy right and you
start to think like well everyone seems
happier than I am and it's because
you're not living for fulfillment I mean
the things that you the the emotional
gratification education so I can't talk
at all the emotional gratification of
achieving something is so important to
the human psyche that if we live in a
culture where you just get handed a lot
of stuff to Tim's earlier Point uh then
you never feel that true satisfaction
it's very difficult to find direction
for your life because you can't find
something that may that makes you feel
fulfilled and well and largely because
there's no self-sacrifice involved in
any of their behaviors and if you're not
ever doing anything for others it's very
hard to feel any sense of value I think
so I guess we'll see the one thing I
think that matters too is we bring up
quite a bit that um in the 2000s
conservatives just had more kids
so we're seeing this trend very likely
due to just sheer numbers yeah well and
that and that Trend will maintain if not
grow absolutely the the Liberals are
more likely to abort their kids and
sterilize their kids right that's it you
can't beat math baby no no that
trajectory is going to uh go parabolic
potentially I've seen too many of these
stories right there's and I know the
feminists are going to lose their minds
over this there's the New York Post
where the woman was like I'm struggling
to find a man who makes the same amount
of money as me I'm telling you like we
see these Trends and data doesn't mean
it's absolute doesn't mean I'm correct
of course 100 I'm saying I see this as a
possibility you've got these women who
are trying to be with men but it's like
oh
you're 35 you make 60 000 a year and
you're trying to date a 35 year old guy
who makes 60 000 a year guess what that
35 year old guy who makes 60k a year he
could be doing better but he's dating a
28 year old hmm he's got money he's got
an apartment he's not why would he date
you and that and and that bothers
feminists quite a bit but that's the New
York Post reporting that's it that's
right now that's what happens of course
I mean John Peterson talks about the IQ
scale for women right like it's much
harder for high IQ women to find
partners because they need someone who's
smarter than them like I've always said
it would be difficult for me to date
someone who is less conservative than I
am because it would feel like a it would
feel like a mismatch right why is it
harder for women to find if they're high
IQ to find a high IQ made I don't
understand
yeah there's less men that are
intelligent no no no for them to choose
from if you have to be sure it Narrows
their it there's not as many yeah yeah
okay okay don't exist so so this is the
thing like a really dumb woman
she's got lots of options but it's easy
to date up and and you know right that's
interesting thing like how do you
describe it for men women want to date
up that's what they call it right
someone who is more powerful more
attractive wealthier more capable
Crossing up minimum day of Crossing down
man is a cross and down men will date
across and and so they don't want a
woman that's smarter not well not just
smarter but but social Mobility money or
stuff like that so like if if you're
like if you start date if you get with a
girl and she doesn't make more money
than you one of the best predictors
about or one of the high predictors of
divorce is if she does make more money
because she starts making more money
she'll probably you're probably gonna
end up in a divorce the left takes the
data on this but yeah because it's
reality because they're coming the
Communists don't want to accept that men
are attracted to appearance and women I
should say this that men have a tendency
to be attracted towards appearance to a
great degree and women have a tendency
to be attracted towards power and status
to a great degree which boils down to
men are attracted to women that look
able to produce Offspring and women are
attracted to men that look able to
protect them it's that so if you're rich
you got a lot of money you have
resources you can protect women you're
big and strong you can you're physically
fit you can protect women wait so you're
telling me that the immutable laws of
human nature remain intact feel you know
let's talk about men and women and
penises and vaginas you know who's got
what you know because it you know it's
getting confusing these days apparently
well I I was just thinking about it
because I was like have I dated a woman
that's smarter than me and but then I'm
like am I am I too narcissistic to even
acknowledge if I've dated a woman that's
smarter than me have you ever have you
ever had an attraction to someone who
sometimes feels like wearing pants
foreign
yes that makes you bisexual
no no no men wear pants when we wear
dresses oh and if if a woman sometimes
decides to wear pants then she said
pants she's non-binary
right because the question my wardrobe
tonight yeah well uh Hannah Claire over
here is a guy oh interesting just one of
the boys
that's right oh my God
and he was like yeah I don't think women
should be able to wear dresses but I
realize I've sort of lost this battle
dresses I should be it shouldn't be
shouldn't be able to wear pants Sheamus
said that of course
quick shot at the same as I will be on
his show on Thursday wait he doesn't
want women wearing pants yeah but he
realizes on that one he's like as soon
as you put that so so if if the argument
is that social constructs define whether
you're a man or a woman that's literally
the point yeah so if like someone who
was male decides one day to wear a dress
if you're straight you should be
attracted to them that's the argument we
get from the left but but it literally
is thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time